hey guys the 25-hour extra life charity
is going on right now yes 25 hour I'm
going to be streaming for a long day
filled with gaming and laughs and fun
all for a great cause if you don't know
we're raising money like thousands of
gamers all across the nation are raising
money through extra life for their local
hospitals I'm raising money for the
Cincinnati Children's Hospital which is
a great Hospital I'm really proud to be
representing them and currently we're in
second place for the largest amount
donated in the entire event that's
absolutely incredible so thank you guys
so much and if you hadn't haven't
donated already the first link in the
description will take you to the extra
life donation page where you can make
your contribution and remember all of
these contributions are tax-deductible
they'll give you a receipt as soon as
you're done with your donation that you
can use to save a little money on taxes
and also you get to benefit yourself and
benefit a great cost so please join me
today the second link is the link to my
livestream please help us out in
whatever way you can and if you can't
make a donation um it doesn't matter
just help spread the word about the page
share it on Facebook share it on Twitter
let's make this the number one charity
on extra life so thank you guys so much
and I'll see you at the live stream bye
bye bye